straight to Scotty on Parliament Square
and the senior national coordinator has
declared this a terrorist incident and
although we remain open-minded to the
motive a full counterterrorism
investigation is already underway this
is led by the Mets counterterrorism
commander at this stage I will confirm
what we know has happened but I will not
speculate we received a number of
different reports which included a
person in the river a car in collision
with pedestrians and a man armed with a
knife officers were already in that
location as part of routine policing but
immediately additional officers were
sent to the scene and that included
firearms offenses we are working closely
with the London Ambulance Service and
the London Fire Brigade I'd like to
repeat our request for the public to
avoid the following areas Parliament
Square Whitehall Westminster Bridge
Lambeth bridge Victoria Street's up to
the junction with Broadway and the
Victoria Embankment up to embankment
tube stations this is to allow emergency
services to deal with its ongoing
incident there is an ongoing
investigation being led by the
counterterrorism command and we would
ask anybody who has images or film of
the incident to pass those to the police
we know there are a number of casualties
including police officers but at this
stage we cannot confirm numbers or the
nature of these injuries our response
will be ongoing for some time and it is
important that we gather all possible
information and evidence Public Safety
is our top priority and we are reviewing
our policing stars across London and
throughout the capital this afternoon
there will be additional officers on
duty and deployed across the capital I
would like the public to remain vigilant
and let us know if they see anything
suspicious that causes them concern and
if they do to dial 999 immediately the
acting commissioner
Craig Mackay is being treated as a
significant witness as he was at the
scene when the incident started whilst
he is not injured it would be
inappropriate for him to be here to talk
about the incident at this stage our
thoughts and his thoughts are with all
of those involved and responding things
in this evening I would stress that
anyone has information
about today's incident that is they are
urged to call a 800 seven eight nine
three two one and our distress if the
public have any information or s see
anything suspicious to dial 999
immediately and I'm not going to
speculate we've got you'll see the
response that we've got here officers
responding I want to stress that it's
our priority to keep London safe people
going home this evening we'll see
additional officers deployed both armed
and unarmed across London in order to
achieve that I'm and I've told you what
information I have and I will we will
keep continue to keep you updated as we
find things out I'm not prepared to
speculate